hey Fandango movie clips I'm Kristian
harloff this is Dan Perrault
this is Tiffany Smith we are about to
watch the force awakens final trailer
and all star wars trailer how excited
are you then extremely excited almost
dangerously so
I'm so so worried about my body what's
gonna do when we actually see this very
letter because of Exile yeah remember
those two big reveals that we got in the
little teaser is the first time we saw
kylo Ren the second one we saw jakku and
wants to be starters what's up in with a
lightsaber what we see a lightsaber
battle that is another thing as well
these are all those questions are coming
at us right now we're gonna watch we're
gonna react you guys are gonna watch
this react and then we'll do a little
review afterwards here we guys what if
it ends at the very end of two
lightsabers just watch this we will see
it and then black
who are you
bb8 I know
whoa
great voice
ah
Wow there were stories about what
happened music uh-huh
whoo the rain
hold on
all the battles are so awful
Oh
what the force joy you're mocking to you
it's calling to you yeah
Wow
oh nice did you see the force is calling
to you just let it oh my god
alright quiet you that is unbelievable
alright guys first I know I know we're
gonna watch that a million times first
thing I just real quick have to say
Knights of Ren Tiffany you saw that you
are going as crazy as I am right now
what did you do Knights of Ren moment
freaked me out but also the moment with
kylo and Poe what was he doing no reach
his hand he had blood on his face I was
like yeah is Poe actually a bad guy is
he siding with him or was he using the
Force to like noise torture what so much
mystery and as I said like I want some
of that mystery like we're really not
getting too many details as to what is
the plot of this movie um I loved how
central han Solo was to this how like it
seems like I don't know if the force is
gone but it really seems like you know
the days of old have passed and like he
said all the stories are true which is
amazing to him reflect on like well what
you just said there was absolutely
essential to this trailer was the fact
that this guy the old bringing in the
new this is what they say this movie was
gonna be and him telling the story about
the Jedi and everything was true like
and kylo saying I will I'll finish what
you started yeah Vader mask like what
was interesting was when that shot that
we saw Vega in the little Instagram
thing we see you saw it again this time
we know he's fighting hi there and kylos
helmet isn't off you see the hair yeah
through I mean there is some I love the
trim we think that voice at the
beginning was Maz Kanata I think there
was like a tiny moment where she's
talking to Ray yeah and she says I'm
know is she right right because it seems
like I mean what we were overall
thoughts Dan of the trailer what you
think well you know it also makes ray
really put her in the forefront as like
the lead character of this movie it's it
really seems like it's gonna be told for
her perspective which i think is
interesting so I'm looking forward to
that don't know Luke no I don't know we
didn't even hear his voice
his face it really might be the lost
Luke story I mean as you said like what
are they gonna be searching for him I
really think that's exactly what it is
because even from a little glimpse of
the story that we got here
yeah the story is about the force
awakening you see right like you said
like they're they let it let the force
let it in like it's calling to you all
that stuff and the way that they're just
combining all the characters my gosh
that was incredible I am on board that
is everything like a crying about and
also the fact that we saw a lake our
first time we haven't seen Leia in the
face right now folks are in the pine
this behind-the-scenes thing but like
this was the poster where you're right
yeah all right that was our trailer
reaction and our thoughts now it comes
down to you guys please comment and let
us know what did you think of the
trailer did you love it did you hate it
okay what did were your overall thoughts
and what do you think will happen in the
film real quick down the line one word
reaction to the trailer Dan magic
Christian it's kind of tours with mind
blowing and mine perfect that's that
[ __ ] subscribe to this channel leave
your comments I gotta watch it again
let's watch babies watch it--watch it
will come back oh come back